สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรค่ะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
8 หรอ
วันเสาร์ที่ 18 ใช่ค่ะวันเสาร์ที่ 18
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 17 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 19
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้
[ปรบมือ]
23:00 น
:5 ทุ่ม
5 ทุ่มกี่นาที
34 นาที
ค่ะ
เวลาที่ดึกๆเนี่ย
มึงไม่อยากทำงานแล้วจะไปเล่นเกมค่ะผู้
หญิง 5 ทุ่มจะมาทำงานทำไมคะเอ้าไม่ต้อง
ไม่ต้องค่ะครูฟ้าเพราะว่า 23:00 นใน
วิดีโอนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าก็จะทำงานก็คือสอน
ภาษาไทยแล้วก็เล่นเกมไปด้วยค่ะ
ครูภาจะทำงานไปด้วยแล้วก็เล่นเกมไปด้วย
ได้ยังไงได้หรอไม่
ได้ไม่ได้ไม่ใช่เกมที่อยู่ในโทรศัพท์ของ
ครูฟ้าค่ะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่แคนดี้ครับ
ไม่ใช่เกมที่อยู่ในโทรศัพท์ของครูฟ้าค่ะ
เกมของครูหญิงครูหญิงเนี่ยมีเกมมาเล่นกับ
ครูฟ้าให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยใช้
สมองนะคะ
ถ้าเกิดไม่มี
มีนิดหน่อยแต่ว่าได้โอเคอยู่แหละแล้วก็
คิดค่ะครูฟ้าเพราะว่าตอนนี้ 5 ทุ่มใช่ไหม
คะนักเรียนถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ย 5 ทุ่มเนี่ย
ดึกแล้วคุณหญิงเนี่ยคิดไม่ออกนะคะแต่ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยเขาแบบ
ไอคิวเขาจะดีมากในช่วงดึกๆอย่างนี้นะคะ
ถูกต้องค่ะเอาล่ะครูหญิงครูหญิงมีเกมอะไร
ที่ต้องใช้ไอคิวดีๆมาเล่นกับครูฟ้าหรอคะ
ครูฟ้าอยากเล่นเกมที่ไม่มีไอคิวไม่ได้ค่ะ
เพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องใช้ IQ มากๆเราจะ
ได้ IQ ดีๆค่ะครูฟ้า
นี่ค่ะคือเกมของครูหญิงในรูปนี้เนี่ย
ครูฟ้ามีใครบ้าง
ในรูปนี้มี
ผู้ชาย 2 คน
ใช่ค่ะผู้ชาย 2 คนฝรั่งเป็น
เขาไม่ใช่คนไทยใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้ารู้ได้ยังไง
ว่าผู้ชาย 2 คนนี้ไม่ใช่คนไทยเอาเขามีผม
สีส้มและเคราสีส้มเขามีผมสีส้มและเคราสี
ส้มผู้ชาย 2 คนนี้เป็นพี่น้องกัน
อายุ 20 เป็นพี่
อะไรเนี่ยครูหญิงคนนี้อายุ 20 เป็นพี่ใช่
ไหมคะคนนี้อายุ 18 เป็นน้องไม่ใช่ค่ะผู้
ชาย 2 คนนี้ไม่ใช่พี่น้องกันผู้ชาย 2 คน
นี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่เพื่อนกันด้วย
แต่ผู้ชาย 2 คนนี้ไม่ใช่คนไทยนะ
ไม่ใช่คนไทยถูกต้องค่ะเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ย
ทำผมสีส้มได้นะคะผู้ชายไทยเนี่ยแต่เราไม่
ทำหนวด
ตำรวจทำเคราสีส้มนะคะ
เราไม่เปลี่ยนสีเนอะนี้เป็นฝรั่งนะคะก็
เป็นผู้ชาย 2 คนผู้หญิงให้ชื่อและกันนะ
ผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยชื่อโจ
เจโอเจ
ไหมคะ
โชว์กับมาร์คใช่ไหมคะมาร์คเนี่ยใส่แว่นตา
ทำไมใส่แว่นตาแต่แว่นตาดำนะแล้วก็เขาก็มี
กล้องใช่ไหมสะพายกล้องเรียกสะพายไหมคล้อง
คล้องกล้องกล้องถ่ายรูปไว้ที่คอนะคะดูจาก
การแต่งตัวเนาะเสื้อผ้าแล้ว 2 คนเนี่ยก็
มีกระเป๋าก็คิดว่าสองคนน่าจะเดินทางเนอะ
ไปทำงานนะคะเพราะว่าครูฟ้าดูแล้วเนี่ยคิด
ว่าผู้ชาย 2 คนนี้เนี่ยนั่งอยู่ที่ไหน
ผู้ชาย 2 คนนี้นั่งอยู่ที่สนามบิน
สนามบินหรอครูฟ้า
ไม่ใช่สนามบินหรอ
ที่รอรถหรอ
ก็สถานีรถไฟไง
มันนึกว่าอะไรก็ไม่รู้
นี่อันนี้คือรางรถไฟใช่ไหมคะอันนี้สำหรับ
ให้รถไฟเนี่ยวิ่งถ้าสนามบินสนามบินเนี่ย
มันต้องติดอันนี้มันเปิดเห็นไหม Open  Air
เราเห็นต้นไม้
ถ้ารอที่สนามบินสนามบินก็จะมีเครื่องบิน
ใช่มั้ยเครื่องบินว่ายังไง
นี่คือถ้ารอเครื่องบินก็ต้องไปที่สนามบิน
แต่ว่าอันนี้เนี่ยสถานีรถไฟค่ะครูฟ้า
เพราะว่านี่คือรางรถไฟครูบาสจะบอกว่าครู
ฟ้าเห็นอันนี้ใช่ไหมเลยคิดว่าสนามบิน
เมื่อลืมว่านั่งอยู่ที่ไหนนะ
คะสองคนเนี่ยอยู่ที่สถานีรถไฟแล้วก็กำลัง
รอรถไฟอยู่อาจจะไม่ได้ไปที่เดียวกันก็ได้
เนาะแต่นั่งรอรถไฟอยู่นะคะก็สถานีรถไฟก็
จะต้องมีนาฬิกาบอกเวลาแล้วก็นี่คือตาราง
รถไฟ
ที่จะบอกว่ารถไฟไปลอนดอนมากี่โมงรถไฟไป
นิวยอร์กอันนี้สถานีไหนคะ
นักเรียนแต่หาก็เป็นสถานีรถไฟนะคะสองคน
เนี่ยก็รอรถไฟอยู่
โจเนี่ยนะคะเขาก็เห็นว่าอุ๊ยรถไฟที่เขาจะ
ขึ้นเนี่ยมาแล้ว
เขาก็เลยหยิบกระเป๋า
แล้วก็เงินเห็นไหมเขาก็หยิบกระเป๋านะคะ
หยิบกระเป๋าถือกระเป๋าขึ้นมาแล้วก็เดินนะ
คะอันนี้เจาะใช่ไหมผู้ชายที่ใส่สูทแต่ง
ตัวดีๆเนี่ยนะคะมิสเตอร์โจ
เขาก็หยิบกระเป๋าแล้วก็กำลังจะไปขึ้นรถไฟ
ใช่ไหมเพราะว่ารถไฟ
แล้วก็
มาร์คเนี่ยเขาก็เห็นรถไฟก็มาเหมือนกันอาจ
จะไปขบวนเดียวกันหรือเปล่า
ใบนี้เนี่ยไม่ใช่ของเขาเขาหยิบขึ้นมาปุ๊บ
เขารู้เลยว่าไม่ใช่กระเป๋าเขา
ไม่รู้นะ
คะก็เลยบอกกับโจว่าโจคุณหยิบกระเป๋าของผม
ไป
โจก็งงหาทำไม
ใช่โจก็งงแล้วก็บอกว่าไม่ใช่ใบนี้กระเป๋า
ของผม
ม้าบอกว่าโจหยิบกระเป๋าของผมไป
โตก็บอกว่าไม่ใช่ใบนี้ของผม
แล้วทำไมมาร์คถึงรู้ว่ากระเป๋าใบนี้เนี่ย
ไม่ใช่ของมาร์ค
กระเป๋า 2 ใบเนี่ยเหมือนกันมากๆ
ถูกต้องค่ะ
เป็นลูกเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมผืนผ้าเหมือนกันสี
อะไรเนี่ยสีเทา
สีเทาเหมือนกันอะไรคะ
มัน
คนละด้าน
ด้วยนะ
ใช่เพราะว่าอันนี้สมมุติว่าฝั่งนี้ใช่ไหม
อยู่ทางซ้ายอันนี้ก็อยู่ทางขวาอย่างนี้
มันกลับด้านกันเท่านั้นอันนี้ก็ I  love
ny อ่านได้นะคะแต่อันนี้ n  y  n  Love
I หรือเปล่า
แต่ว่า
จริงๆแล้ว
โจเนี่ยหยิบกระเป๋าผิดจริงๆมาร์คเนี่ย
รู้ได้ยังไงคะนี่คือฟ้าถ่ายหรือเปล่า
นะคะ
เพราะว่าในกระเป๋าของโจกระเป๋าของโจนะ
กระเป๋าของโจเนี่ยมีไม่ได้มีหมีแพนด้ากับ
แมวอยู่ในกระเป๋านะคะนักเรียนอันนี้คือ
ตุ๊กตาในกระเป๋าของโจรเนี่ยมีตุ๊กตาอยู่ 2
ตัวแต่ในกระเป๋าของม้ามีโทรศัพท์มีสมุดมี
iPad อยู่
มันไม่เหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมของในกระเป๋าเนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกัน
ทำไมมาร์คเขาถึงรู้เวลาที่เขาหยิบกระเป๋า
ขึ้นมาเขาถึงรู้ว่าเฮ้ยใบนี้ไม่ใช่
กระเป๋าผม
เขาถึงว่าโจไงคะว่าคุณเอากระเป๋าผมไป
คำถามก็คือ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
คิดว่า
โจโจเนี่ยนะคะเขารู้ไหมว่าเขาเนี่ยหยิบ
กระเป๋าผิด
เพราะคำถามข้อที่ 1 ก่อนครูฟ้าคิดว่าเขา
รู้ไหมครูฟ้าคิดว่าเขาคิดที่จะหยิบ
กระเป๋าผิดจริงๆไหม
คิดว่าเขารู้นะ
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมครูฟ้าถึงคิดว่าเขารู้เพราะ
ว่าในกระเป๋าก็น่าจะเหตุผลเดียวกันกับ
มาร์คไหมคะน้ำหนัก
มันไม่เหมือนกัน
กระเป๋าของ
โจเนี่ยมันมีแค่ตุ๊กตา
มันต้องเบาอยู่แล้ว
แต่นี่มี iPad โทรศัพท์หนังสือ
มันหนักมากนะคะ
เพราะว่ากระเป๋าม้าเนี่ยเขารู้ว่ากระเป๋า
ของเขาเนี่ยมันหนักใช่ไหมคะอ่าทำไมเขา
หยิบกระเป๋าขึ้นมาเขาก็เลยรู้ว่าเฮ้ยใบ
นี้ไม่ใช่กระเป๋าของผมเพราะว่ามันเบามากๆ
โจก็ต้องรู้สิ
ใช่ไหมโจเอาตุ๊กตามาโจจะไปไหน
แต่งตัวดีมากเลยนะ
แต่ข้างในเนี่ยมี
ตุ๊กตา 2 ตัวเนี่ยนะ
หรือว่าโจเนี่ยนะคะโจเนี่ย
แต่งงาน
และโจก็เลยมีลูก 2 คน
ลูกสาวกูก็เลยเอาตุ๊กตาตุ๊กตาไปให้ลูกนะ
คะ
แต่ในนี้คือตุ๊กตาโจต้องรู้ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะก็ถ้าอย่างนั้นถ้าครูฟ้าคิดว่าโจร
รู้ว่าตัวเองเนี่ยหยิบกระเป๋าผิดใช่ไหมคะ
ตอนที่เขานั่งอยู่เนี่ยมันมีกระเป๋า 2 ใบ
ตอนที่โจหยิบกระเป๋าขึ้นมาตอนที่เขาหยิบ
ขึ้นมาเนี่ยเขาอาจจะไม่ได้ดูว่ากระเป๋า
ของเขาหรือกระเป๋าของมาร์คแต่พอเขาหยิบ
ขึ้นมาแล้วเขาต้องรู้เนาะว่ากระเป๋าใบนี้
ไม่ใช่ของเขามันหนัก
เขาก็ยังเดินไปแล้วพอม้าบอกว่าคุณหยิบ
กระเป๋าผม
เขาก็ยังบอกไม่ใช่ใบนี้กระเป๋าผมถ้าอย่าง
นั้น
โจก็คิดจะขโมยของมาร์คหรอ
อ้าว
ใช่ค่ะ
โจอาจจะคิดอยู่แล้วไงว่า
แล้วมันจะเหมือนกัน
ยังไง
เพราะว่าโจอาจจะรู้ตั้งแต่แรกแล้วก็ตั้ง
ใจหยิบกระเป๋าผิดไง
กระเป๋าผิดเลยหยิบหรือโจอาจจะไม่มีลูกโจ
ไม่ได้แต่งงานแต่โจเอาตุ๊กตามาใส่
เพราะว่าตุ๊กตาราคาไม่แพง
ตุ๊กตา 5 บาท 20 บาทอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
ใช่ไหมคะตุ๊กตาไม่แพงหรือว่า
โจกับม้าเนี่ยอาจจะเจอกันหรือ
โจสมัยโจเนี่ยอาจจะเห็นมาร์คเนี่ยเปิด
กระเป๋าอืม
แล้วก็เห็นว่าอุ๊ยในกระเป๋าของมาร์ค
มีโทรศัพท์มี iPad
จอก็เลยคิด
ในกระเป๋าของมาร์คมี iPad  Pro อยากได้
ใช่ไหมคะโจก็เลยหยิบกระเป๋าผิดโจตั้งใจ
ขโมยกระเป๋าของมาร์คเพราะว่ามาร์คไม่ได้
ให้ไงมาร์คไม่ได้บอกว่าอ่ะผมให้คุณมะไม่
ได้ให้โจรหยิบมาก็แปลว่าโจรเนี่ยจะขโมย
ของของมาร์คหรือเปล่าเพราะว่า iPad
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยมีราคาแพงใช่ไหมอาจจะ 30,000
บาท
โทรศัพท์นี่แพงมากนะคะ
อาจจะ
50,000 บาทอย่างนี้อ่ามันเป็นของแพงใช่
ไหมโจก็อาจจะอยากขโมยก็ได้
อย่างนี้ทำไมไม่ค่อยต้องคิดอะไรเลยอ่ะ
หรือว่าผู้หญิงถามผิดวะเนี่ยผู้หญิง
จริงคือคำตอบมันก็ง่ายอยู่แล้วไงมันเป็น
เพราะน้ำหนักไง
ใช่ๆๆๆค่ะ
นี่ไงคะเพราะว่าเนี่ยแหละค่ะนักเรียนอัน
นี้คือกระเป๋าใบนี้เนี่ยของโจใช่ไหม
กระเป๋าใบนี้เนี่ยของมาร์คในผู้หญิงต้อง
ถามครูฟ้าว่ามาร์ครู้ได้ยังไงว่าโจเนี่ย
หยิบกระเป๋าผิดนะ
ว่าคือน้ำหนักนะคะถ้าม้ากูก็ที่กูมาถาม
ครูหญิงว่าเขาตอบเลยไหม
ว่ารู้อยู่แล้วว่ามาหยิบปุ๊บมันรู้เพราะ
ว่ามันเป็นน้ำหนักไงกระเป๋าต้องหนักเท่า
กัน
ชัวร์ค่ะ
คือครูฟ้าบอกว่าครูหญิงไม่ต้องบอกว่าข้าง
ในกระเป๋าโจมีอะไรข้างข้างในกระเป๋าม้ามี
อะไรเนี่ยครูหญิงไม่ต้องบอกแค่เขาหยิบ
กระเป๋าขึ้นมาแล้วเขารู้ว่ามาร์คเนี่ย
หยิบกระเป๋าขึ้นมาแล้วรู้ว่าไม่ใช่
กระเป๋าของเขาเนี่ยครูฟ้าก็รู้แล้วใช่ไหม
คะว่าเป็นเพราะน้ำหนัก
เพราะว่ากระเป๋าเหมือนกันเห็นมั้ยคะนัก
เรียนสติกเกอร์ที่อยู่บนกระเป๋าเหมือนกัน
100% ไม่ใช่ 100% หรอกก็ 99%
ไม่ได้ไง
อย่างเดียวที่ทำให้รู้ก็คือถือขึ้นมา
แล้วก็รู้ว่ามันเบามันหนักก็
ชูใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ากระเป๋าของ 2 คนนี้เนี่ย
น้ำหนักเนี่ยมันต่างกันมากๆของโจรมันเบา
มากๆเลยอ่ะส่วนของมาร์คเนี่ยนะคะมันหนัก
ใช่ไหมมันหนักมากๆมันก็เลยแยกได้ถ้าอย่าง
นั้นครูฟ้าคิดว่า
โจโจคิดขโมยกระเป๋าของมาร์คไหน
เอาตุ๊กตามาใช่ไหมตุ๊กตาหมี
เอาตุ๊กตามาเพราะโจคิดมาขโมยกระเป๋า
อยู่แล้ว
[เพลง]
ใช่ไหมเพราะว่ากระเป๋าตุ๊กตาเนี่ยมันถูก
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าบอกจะ 10 บาท 20 บาทแต่
iPhone  iPad เนี่ยมันแพงใช่ไหมโจก็อยาก
จะขโมยของของมาร์คนะคะนักเรียนนักเรียน
คิดเหมือนครูฟ้าไหม
นักเรียน
ใช่ค่ะนักเรียนคิดว่า
โจรคิดจะขโมยกระเป๋าของมาร์คไหมหรือว่า
จริงๆแล้วโจเนี่ยไม่รู้
โจแค่หยิบผิด
นักเรียนก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราได้นะคะว่า
โจคิดขโมย
หรือแค่หยิบผิด
ยังไง comment บอกได้นะคะส่วนวีดีโอนี้นะ
คะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนนะแล้วเราเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]
บ๊าย